ich glaube aber der wille war auf jeden
fall da wenn man sich so diese leute ihr
habt ja die aufnahmen gesehen von drin
also haben wir wirklich die worte
gefehlt
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt leute ich weiß ja
wie mein video gesehen habt wo ich
letzte woche gegen das schlechteste
asiatische restaurant in meiner stadt
getestet habe als ich wohne in köln für
die sich wissen
[Musik]
und ich habe mir gedacht das war so
interessant wir machen einfach mal
weiter so oft in den kommentaren
geschrieben dass ich doch mal nicht
schlecht ist pizza ausprobieren soll
und ja das machen wir heute und ich muss
sagen es war gar nicht mal so leicht die
schlechteste pizza zu ermitteln weil in
köln gibt es bestimmt noch 500 bis 1000
pizza restaurants oder pizzerien wie
auch immer wenn nicht sogar noch mehr
also da bin ich mir auch nicht wundern
deswegen also ich habe lange
recherchiert und bin auf eine gestoßen
die wirklich anscheinend die
schlechteste ist es sind sicherlich auch
nicht alle online registriert ja und ich
bin werde ich mal gespannt was mir heute
so passieren wird das große problem war
als ich dachte wenn ich am anfang gibt
es keine pizzeria die eine extrem
schlechte bewertung hat weil wenn man
das hier mal anschaut vier sterne vier
sterne 444 über vier also das also alles
über vier stern eigentlich da war ich
dann erstmal ein bisschen traurig bis
ich dann auf diese hier gestoßen bin
wird natürlich wieder zensiert ich
möchte hier niemandem etwas böses ich
habe absolut keine pizza gefunden die
schlechter bewertet war als die hier
beweist auch ganz wichtig ist zu
unterscheiden zwischen pizza restaurant
oder italienisches restaurant gleich mal
und pizza lieferservice weil es gibt
auch extrem viel lieferservice
lieferservice schreibt mir gerne die
richtige bezeichnung für die mehrzahl
von lieferservice in den kommentaren auf
jeden fall muss man ja da unterscheiden
und ich möchte in ein restaurant gehen
wo ich auf da essen kann das ist mir
eigentlich das wichtigste für diese
videos jetzt schauen wir uns mal die
rezensionen von dem laden an natürlich
kann man da auch bestellen aber das kann
man eigentlich fast überall in köln wir
haben eine gesamtbewertung von 2,3 was
wirklich extrem herausgestochen ist dann
und wie schaut erst mal die bewertungen
an
von wirklich nur den leuten die auch vor
ort gegessen haben hier gilt es zum
beispiel direkt am anfang sogar drei
sterne
die pfizer ist super aber ich würde sie
zu hause essen das ladenlokal ist nicht
sehr schön zum drinsitzen alles andere
wie zum beispiel die linien sind nicht
so mein ding aber pizza können sie wohl
niemals hingehen total unkooperativ kein
umtausch reklamation für sehr schlechtes
es salat für sechs euro im wert von 20
cent
das ist eine pampe aus nudeln und massig
soße schmeckt mittel ciabatta für 4
portionen und sehr spärlich belegt darum
grund hat man muss sagen viele
kommentare sind ja auch dabei von leuten
die anscheinend doch da bestellt haben
also man kann halt wie gesagt und auch
gestellt man kann aber verordneten also
ich schon gesagt eine schlechtere
pizzeria habe ich nicht gefunden
deswegen bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wir
fahren da jetzt durch hin und ja ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim zugucken
lass mir sehr gerne daumen nach oben da
wenn ihr wollt dass weitere teile zu
diesem format kommen und schreibt auch
in die kommentare
mit welcher erstens richtung nicht dass
man machen soll keine ahnung türkisch
griechisch keine ahnung gibt ja genug
also ich will gar nicht angelaufen
wir fahren los und wir sehen uns dann
gleich im auto ist gleich heute was geht
ab also ich würde sagen wir verlost ich
bin irgendwie immer gespannt ich werde
natürlich gleich wieder alles beim handy
mit film weil ich diese kamera nicht mit
drei nehmen kann das feld folgt das auch
so also handy aber wir müssen jetzt
erstmal durch köln fahren hat das um 17
30 also genau im berufsverkehr so leute
ich bin jetzt da ich muss mal wieder
sagen ich stehe super scheiße aber das
macht egal weil heute würde ich wirklich
in dem restaurant auch essen das lustige
ist nicht weit
nicht weit von hier ist auch das
restaurant vom letzten part also diese
asiatische laden da ja also ich glaube
diese gegend hat ein händchen für
vielleicht der restaurants zumindest von
der bewertung her
ich bin gespannt was heute ist heute ist
eine pizzeria wie schon gesagt habe ja
auch jetzt stehe ich hier genau auf dem
fahrradweg auf
naja wenn ich ab gestoppt werde sei
nicht sauer wenn einmal mehr werbung im
video
[Musik]
hier war lukas zu bestellen ok
ich setz mich davor leuchteten
[Musik]
leute und bin ich denn hier gelandet
hatte das schott nicht erlangen ich
glaube aber der wille war auf jeden fall
mal da wenn man sich so dieses plakat
anguckt aber auf jeden fall nicht lange
also ich muss aber sagen die speisekarte
sieht gut aus aber leute was ist das
leute hier habe ich dann mal so getan
als wenn ich telefonieren würde damit
man vielleicht auch ein bisschen die
küche sieht hat nicht ganz so geklappt
aber ich hoffe ich konnte euch einen
guten einblick verschaffen so leute ich
bin wieder draußen
hier sind lebende wenn man da rein
schauen da denke ich mir was was geht da
drin vor
also weitere infos gleich muss jetzt
erst mal stellt zu meinem auto weil das
steht im parkverbot alter ich hatte das
schon mal ich habe irgendwann mal so
einen burger laden getestet und da war
das ähnlich
aber leute ihr habt ja die aufnahmen
gesehen von drin also haben wir wirklich
die worte gefehlt wir schauen jetzt mal
kurz hier rein weil die pizza vielleicht
ist ja ganz gut so wer weiß gehört ich
jedoch endlich ganz meister
wir fahren jetzt erst mal nach hause
christian gewonnen gutes tun so schlimm
und dann erzähle ich euch noch ein paar
heftige story bis gleich das war wieder
ein erlebnis hier absolut übrigens ich
habe mich dazu entschlossen die
mitzunehmen
einfach weil das zwar ein restaurant da
vorne ist man kann glaube ich auch da
ist aber der typ hat mich gar nicht
gefragt ob ich da essen will und da
wurde ich auch gar nicht bedient ihr
habt ja vielleicht gesehen am anfang
musste bis nach ganz hinten laufen und
ich hatte auch keinen bock nicht da hin
zu setzen zwischen diese ganzen kartons
und pizza zu essen da fahr ich lieber
entspannt nach hause und probiert die da
vielleicht ist ja ganz gut so leute
wieder zu hause
ja also ich erzähle ich jetzt gleich man
fast alles was in diesem laden so abging
ich weiß gar nicht was ich alles
aufgenommen habe so herzlich willkommen
zurück in meinem zimmer
ich weiß nicht an die die mich fragen
allerdings warum ist sie eigentlich
immer in deinem zimmer wenn ich hier in
köln mit in unserer wohnung als ich
irgendwie immer in meinem zimmer zu
hause woods war aber hier nicht
irgendwie entspannter hier keine ahnung
da ja auf jeden fall ich hatte euch ja
noch irgendein pastorius versprochen wir
können nicht erst mal die pizza öffnen
also sieht die aus ich finde es sieht
eigentlich ganz gut aus um ehrlich zu
sein
schön dünn ich probiere einfach mal ein
stück bevor jetzt wartet ja alle darauf
ist ja ganz klar und dann erzähle ich
euch den rest also haben eine ganz
einfache pizza mit paprika drauf also
guten appetit
[Musik]
was man jetzt natürlich ist ein bisschen
als hintergedanken hat ich habe ja die
kirche gesehen ich war ja wirklich vor
ort und das ist halt alles andere als
hygienisch gewesen
habt ihr auch gesehen und das jetzt aber
fair vom geschmack hat zu bewerten würde
ich sagen dass die pizza soweit okay ist
also tief lag ganz normal wieder
durchschnitt ja also es ist halt okay
das hat mich sechs euro 90 euro kostet
das ist für seine rote filz euch für
verschätzen 30 zentimeter durchmesser
auch in ordnung trotzdem möchte ich
jetzt noch mal auch nur ein paar sachen
eingehen und zwar habe ich mich am
anfang da hingesetzt und ford in dem
laden sah man ja wirklich noch so eine
tafel und so also da hat sich jemand
irgendwann mal richtig mühe gegeben im
internet steht ja auch dass sie sich
eigentlich ein restaurant und ein
lieferservice handelt also man kann da
anscheinend auftritt essen könnte man ja
auch da standen ja auch so tische und so
eine theorie ist dass jetzt am anfang
auch als restaurant aufbauen wollten
allerdings die meisten leute über
lieferservice bestellt haben oder dann
ist das mit der zeit immer so weiter vor
sich hin geschliffen bis das halt
irgendwann so aussagen wie jetzt also
das ist ja ein laden da kümmern die sich
um nichts außer darum das halt die
pizzen rausgehen und alles was an dreck
anfällt oder an müll abfall schwert
irgendwo hin geschoben wo gerade noch
platz und vielleicht kommt sowas dann
auch durch den besitzerwechsel zustand
ich habe keine ahnung auf jeden fall war
ich wirklich schockiert so von der
innenausstattung da und wie gesagt ich
wollte am anfang wirklich da ist ja dann
macht man das beim nächsten mal was ich
auch noch gesehen habe zeige ich euch ja
auch gerne auch mal da war noch so ein
typ der tat mir aber irgend ein bisschen
leid der wohl irgendwie ich weiß nicht
er wurde nicht so ganz gut behandelt von
einem klub die pizza gemacht hat ich
weiß auch nicht vielleicht habe ich das
auch falsch interpretiert keine ahnung
auf jeden fall muss er die ganze zeit
irgendwie so gemüse schälen
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung was was da genau
gemacht hat weiß ihr euch damit
auskennen oder so schreibt ihr das sehr
gerne mal die kommentare weil es
interessiert mich sehr
ansonsten war es mal wieder ein
richtiges erlebnis noch krasser als beim
letzten mal
schreibt mir sehr gerne in die
kommentare von welcher richtung
restaurant ihres noch sehen wollt und
das kennt auch nach oben dafür weitere
paten die pizza kann ich auf jeden fall
noch weiter essen also pizza ok rest
naja leute und das war's dann eigentlich
auch schon mit dem heutigen video ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie schon
gesagt und wir sehen uns morgen wieder
gibt es ein neues video jeden freitag
ist auch um 19 uhr schalteten das was
von mir hat rein